dieser 1 markus nicht die ganze zeit es
ist ein verrückter junge ist das lexikon
ständig laufen hallo ich in meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
spontanen games runde
ich bin gerade relativ ich sag mal gut
drauf warum ist einfach weil ich hab
gerade ein video fertig gestellt was
woran ich sechs stunden gesessen habe
also dieses video von einer 1.4.2010 von
braid kraft die ip schreibe ich euch in
die beschreibung und der typ meinte
gerade also break den kenne ich vom ts
der ist ganz nett also der kanal von dem
es auch eine beschreibung und der meinte
ich soll es gt4 also ich bin wirklich
auf den server gekommen und er hat mir
dann gamon rallye startet game already
started kann ja mal schreiben und er hat
mir dann gesagt ja cool jetzt bisher
drauf da hat er mich darauf diese
dingens tafel bums dich weg hier
geschrieben aufwartete youtuber tafel
moment wo bin ich werde mich irgendwo
draufgeschrieben da das fand ich toll
nicht weil ich war wirklich einmal kurz
drauf und dann hat er mich drauf
geschrieben das war nicht ganz cool und
jetzt habe ich gedacht ja kommen kann
ich eigentlich mit spielen hier sind
noch ein paar leute die mich kennen also
ich hab mir ein bisschen mit den
gekettet hier im chat
hallo kongo also eigentlich ganz cool
und wohin wollen wir also ich fragte
einfach ganz kurz
wohin wir gehen wollen oder hat dabei
ein verzaubertes er in schwerte sehr
schön
ok alle es geht schon fünf okay bin drin
okay es ist aber ne coole web also
einfach nur eine spontane runde hankel
games hierfür den ich weiß nicht leisten
auf den zweit kann oder auf der skala
hoch ich mache das man hier so auf 31
prozent
ich weiß noch nicht genau wie ich das
wahrscheinlich den boden besser machen
kann man gar nichts erstellen hey lass
es sein hallo das ist ein juhu endlich
mit konkreter und breit zocken ja es
keine 17 von 24 in der arena
vielleicht klappt ja ich denke eher dass
wir zu laufen kommt ccn arena 65 5 oder
naja ok starting inception zeigten sich
denke dass alle mir hinterher lauf und
das ist dass ich deswegen ganz schnell
verkaufen werde
gebt mir sachen hh alle weg von mir so
gibt es in grace dingens ich weiß gar
nicht also ich musste auch in schwandorf
ich muss sagen ich bin ja ein totaler
hunger games nun aber ich finde es
gerade sehr geil auf diesem server dass
mir wirklich keiner hinterherläuft und
das finde ich immer was ganz wichtig auf
solchen servern das einem wirklich nicht
alle hinterher laufen so dass man die
möglichkeit hat auch wenn man youtuber
ist sag ich mal so ein bisschen ein an
ein kleines eine gewisse privatsphäre
hier gebrauchen davon gebrauch zu machen
da ist nix grace period ended hier sind
noch ganz viele sachen zdf hatte da
unten ist einer den punch ich jetzt wenn
er hoch kommt gebe ich den gebe ich bis
vor das war ein gebe ich ihm habe ihm
geschildert von kannst du kennst du mich
noch
jo heim marcus popp irgendwie bekannt
vor
also da ist der einem merkurs wartete
ich sollte man ganz groß mit milito
hatte jetzt habe ich viereinhalb jetzt
habe ich verwandelt noch keine ahnung
hier habe ich noch so ein paar kappen
nun schwört also das ist echt laut ich
mach das mal kurz ein bisschen leiser wo
konkret dass youtube hat kann er nicht
sein
oh je jetzt irgendwas in flammen gut ich
werde mal ganz kurz weitergehen ich
frage mich gerade wie viele noch leben
kann ich irgendwie specialist in active
kanal live aus dem europa okay gut ich
laufe einfach ein bisschen weiter hier
sind ja schon alle türen offen
das heißt sterben die ganze zeit leute
habe ich denke ich bin ganz gut
ausgerüstete sicher bald schon eine
rüstung ich habe schon schwert und wie
gesagt ich kann ich jetzt einfach nur
empfehlen also seitdem ich hier drauf
bist echt eigentlich ganz cool
man hat hier seine privatsphäre das
finde ich eigentlich ganz wichtig auf
zwei man dass das nicht so ist so ok ich
war schon so dass ich darauf gekommen
und natürlich viele meinten hey bist du
der echte hey du bist ein fake
das ist eigentlich eine ganz wichtige
reaktion sage ich mal dass man da somit
umgeht das finde ich sehr toll von den
usern hier dass sie sofort denkt sich in
vechta bin also wenn ich jetzt wirklich
eigentlich ganz gut weil ich sonst auch
nie auf server gehe aber dass es halt
diesmal so gewesen ich hab die ip hält
auch weil twitter gepostet dass sich
hier drauf bin
eine melone warte kann ich die melone
hier hinsetzen irgendwo frage ich mich
gerade cool
markus komme ich meinem team bald die
genuss sachen 1 markus was hat er
geschrieben keine ahnung ok cool so wenn
du mir sachen gibt dann wird das
natürlich nicht abschlagen
so darf ich dich in skype als können
nach immer klingt moment erst spielen
erstmal gucken wir mal weiter habe ich
mir hier nicht alles geschenkt bekommen
erst dann auch ihn wieder lustlos na ja
also ich meine das hatten wir ungefähr
ein halbes rüstungs links gegeben also
ist das jetzt auch nicht allzu schlimm
und er will nur nett sein sowie können
des weiteren laufen
vielleicht ist seine neffen etwas aber
dass noch eine kiste da sind wieder ganz
viele sachen drin
das hatte ich ja noch nie wirklich dass
ich so eine große auswahl habe kann es
schon mal sein
in der perle kann ich durch werfen warte
ich guck mal kurz bei liszt life 1 2 3 4
ich höre hier wirklich nur blitze
eingeschlagen heißt das jetzt eigentlich
das wenn blitze eingeschlagen dass ich
dann sehr wohl die anderen sind die
anderen tribute von panem oder was heißt
zum blitz fest gar nicht komme ich da
irgendwie rein hallo sie auf eine bank
hier break break kraft und konkreter
sind die keine ahnung bestimmt so die
behinderten die es gibt
ich glaube ich das ganze doch auf dem
hauptbahnhof weil das ist eigentlich
eine ganz gute runde nur diese blöden
blitz aber jetzt gerade habe ich ja
irgendwie meine ruhe und die kommen
nicht mehr als gerade technische vhv von
crafter zu nerven das mache ich schon
sie schreiben all eigentlich nerven
falsch nerven hier bin frau geschrieben
dass eine kiste da muss ich irgendwie
hoch dass eine kiste es sind wieder
sachen an wenn ihr habe ich doch alle
schon da ist auch eine kiste wir sind ja
echt krass viele kisten was ich
eigentlich ganz cool fände was stakes da
aber was ist besser gold schwert oder
ein schwert erwarte ich mach das mal
ganz kurz auf 15 damit das jetzt nicht
so viel stört 36
ich muss halt irgendwie rum kommen oder
haben die welt einfach irgendwie
abgehört schnitten sage ich mal
einer meint ich soll zum spawn kommen
denkste
wenn er will er sich zum spot hat er
bestimmt so ein diamant schwert und
alles hier ist eine treppe oder auf eine
kiste und das sind spieler so viele
sachen wird brauche ich doch gar nicht
alles ich hab da nichts da es alle gäste
gleich mit inventar von jetzt gut dann
werde ich sagen was andere kiste ja ich
würde sagen wir begeben uns dann noch
mal langsam zum spawn ich meinen hut vor
ihnen sonst machen wir können jetzt
natürlich alle sachen aus guckt euch
unser inventar an das ist schon krass
ich soll eine kiste ist dass es hier
du kannst runter sehen dann geht auch
runter steht der jackpot
muss man irgendwelche druckplatten sind
aber schlechte erfahrungen mit den atem
an schlager mails ein paar sachen hier
die ganzen scheiß teil der bau ja gar
nicht fischer partner saic sowas ist
sind also die map an sich ist wirklich
sehr schön gemacht
wenn man ein bisschen jump we'll eine
kiste also dieser 1 markus will die
ganze zeit es ist einfach ein verrückter
juni ist das entwickeln ständig laufen
der findet uns doch nie nie wirst du uns
finden marcus bosse respekt hätte ich
konnte locker vielleicht respekt respekt
take on kraft ich weiß nicht also
vielleicht jetzt auch noch eine kiste
auch schon leer das auch noch eine kiste
dies bestimmt auch schon länger mio
so ich laufe einfach zurück zum das sehr
schön
nein du nimmst du nicht den main reisen
schwert hier weisen schwert was schmeiße
stand weg naja war okay da hinten sind
überall noch kisten aber ich brauche ja
nix mehr ich will einfach nur zum spawn
gelang das auch nichts mehr drin was ich
brauche
das war nur noch kisten also ich glaub
jetzt wirklich einfach rum ich muss
irgendwie listig kommen noch drei leute
sind am leben
den namen leon josef beha wie auch schon
mal gelesen wo waren jetzt nochmal der
sportarena gar nicht derweil noch immer
auf seinem platz das heißt bestimmt da
da da das blitz eingeschlagen das heißt
er ist jetzt irgendwie find ob die feine
zeit rast übrigens erlaubt halt nur
keinen minimap also würde ich mal sagen
so ganz normale regeln von kraft
ok dahin ist der blitz ich habe
irgendwie so das gefühl dass ich jetzt
irgendwie sterbe
prostep jetzt eingeschlagen bis er
eingeschlagen da ist ein name
online rausgeflogen
ok jetzt soll es geschafft verdammt ich
wurde
ich wurde ich bin ja viel mehr drin ich
glaube ich wurde dritter oder so von
keine ahnung 15 leuten die mitgemacht
haben oder sind auf jeden fall paar
leute drauf also als ich drauf gegangen
wenn man glaube ich irgendwie zehn leute
drauf damit imp bei twitter gepostet
also bitte mir bei twitter folgen wenn
ihr auch so solche server zum mitmachen
wollt jetzt sind ein paar mehr leute
drauf ich würde einfach sagen danke fürs
zuschauen
echt eigentlich wollte ich dort auf den
zweit kanal hochladen aber war halt
nachher doch eine ganz witzige runde und
dann würde ich sagen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich definitiv
bei einem daumen hoch freuen und wir
sehen uns hier beim nächsten mal also
wenn ich euch das mal hier zeigen kann
hier sind dann war da war eine wolke ein
paar leute die kennen mich hallo hallo
was willst du denn